[Musique]
la question de bonheur alors parlons-en
les femmes gagnent moins d'argent que
les hommes les femmes sont obligées en
plus de l'argent qu'elles gagnent quand
elle en gagnent moins que les hommes
d'assumer un travail à la maison qui est
gratuite un homme se marie il épouse une
femme de ménage gratis le bonheur c'est
l'indépendance d'abord c'est la liberté
et l'indépendance par là j'entends que
puisque je suis une femme
mon bonheur ne dépendent pas de
quelqu'un d'autre ne dépendent pas d'un
homme par exemple je pense qu'à partir
du moment où mon bonheur dépend d'un
homme je suis une esclave et je ne suis
pas libre
je suis le type de l'esclave je sais
exactement ce que c'est que l'image les
hommes veulent avoir des femmes
moi à partir du moment où je me rends
compte et où je le dis je deviens
quelqu'un de très antipathique pour les
hommes en fait la beauté d'abord une
chose qui passe est une chose sur
laquelle on nous apprend beaucoup à
compter et sur lesquels on nous apprend
pas enfin on nous apprend aussi qu on la
jette un certain moment donné la beauté
parce qu'elle passe parce qu'elle est
plus égale à elle-même célébrités les
duos plus grand des hasards et à l'appui
certainement deux des hommes il me
semble que les femmes en général dès
leur naissance sont conditionnés à
considérer comme le la partie la plus
importante de leur existence
laura les rapports interpersonnels
qu'elles ont avec les autres et en
particulier avec les hommes mais aussi
entre femmes les hommes sont
immédiatement eu conditionnée à
s'appuyer sur autre chose que leurs
rapports interpersonnels
sur une oeuvre sur un travail sur le
fait de gagner leur vie et c'est alors
que les femmes savent très bien que
elles sont acceptées dans la société et
elles réussissent si elles réussissent
dans leurs rapports interpersonnels
c'est-à-dire avec d'autres êtres humains
entre autres et plus particulièrement
des hommes on ne sait pas ce que fait
l'identité d'une femme on n'a jamais vu
on ne suit pas ce que serait une femme
si elle n'était pas dans le
conditionnement dans son environnement
dans tout ce qu'on lui a appris à être
dès l'âge de 10 ont l'âge verbales mais
il ya une culture féminine et une
culture masculine
il est évident par exemple se poser la
question pourquoi est ce que les femmes
ne sont jamais de grands artistes
pourquoi est-ce que depuis la nuit des
temps on parle de michel-ange de de tout
tout ce qui est art dans notre
civilisation est le fait des hommes et
pas des femmes
alors les femmes peuvent s p pense que
elles sont moins doués moins
intelligente que le génie est une chose
qui ne leur appartient pas on peut
décider que les femmes sont inférieures
c'est un c'était une décision qu'on peut
prendre c'est une décision raciste
la question elle que les femmes veulent
se prendre en main elles mêmes elles
veulent parler de racisme là dedans où
elle racisme
où est le racisme qui a ségrégué les
femmes
pourquoi est ce que les femmes ne
peuvent pas flâner dans la rue à minuit
pourquoi est-ce que pourquoi est-ce
qu'elles soient elles les hommes peuvent
flâner tout les à toutes les heures de
la nuit qui comme elle est violent est
ce que c'est les viols les les femmes
qui violent les hommes qui fait la
fabrication qui tient tous les jours nos
politiques je parle pas des mots
féminins qui vous apprennent la mode et
la couture mais je parle des journaux
politiques sont entre les mains de qui
d'une façon générale des hommes
si une femme n'est pas marié les fichus
puisqu'elle gagne pas d'argent ou
pratiquement pas elle n'a pas d'avenir
il ya aucun poster n'y a aucune il ya
aucun avenir pour elle elle est
forcément dépendante du mari
h le mariage est une forme de une forme
disons 2 2 pour prendre un pot énorme
mais une forme de prostitution
la femme se donne physiquement
gratuitement et elle fait le ménage
gratuitement pour un homme
moyennant quoi elle est logée nourrie
mais il faut qu'elle se lève la nuit
pour torcher les gosses et pour les
soigner quand elle a un travail et que
son mari un travail aussi et que les
hommes les enfants sont malades
qu'est ce qui reste à la maison c'est la
femme parce que finalement sa
contribution financière aux ménages est
accessoire c'est quand même l'homme qui
lui continue à travailler
les femmes sont des championnes et à
servir les autres à ne pas s'occuper
d'elle même
elles sont conditionnées à toujours au
service de l'extérieur quitte à se
maquiller d'ailleurs et à tout faire
pour les autres pas pour elle-même mais
pour être accepté par les autres j'ai
les mains qui tremblent je ne suis pas à
mon aise
parce que j'ai trop bas dit il ya un
trop plein beaucoup de femmes ont ce
trop plat en elle
c'est justement ça prouve que leur vie
n'est pas ce qu'elle devrait être
et je crois que c'est très important à
dire parce que je le ressens moi même là
en ce moment il se trouve que étant une
femme je voudrais qu'on sait ce que j'en
suis consciente et que je sais que
beaucoup de femmes partagent pas avec
moi
de là vient sûrement cette agressivité
qui a souvent le mouvement de libération
des femmes et qui n'est pas sympathique
et c'est bien peut-être de là je ne sais
pas si le calme des hommes est tellement
sympathique
[Musique]